because men are naturally protective of
women and it's funny you know I've
always talked about this men didn't have
a secret meeting behind women's backs
Michael we're gonna beat the hell out of
them by the way we're gonna set this
unrealistic standard of beauty I don't
even like boobs and butts so glad to
have this next guest in every every one
of these guest things but honestly this
is where I get out this is actually the
one guest for him we've got Academy
award-winning actors we've had war
heroes all of whom I have great for whom
I have great respect but really was
looking forward to getting this woman
lady she'll she'll clarify with her
pronouns on you can follow her on
YouTube girl rights what just google
that Karen strong thanks so much for
being on Oh No thank you for inviting me
and please don't ever refer to me as a
lady again okay so woman yes definitely
a woman a little bit of a weirdo and
other than that and my ID my preferred
pronoun pronouns are whatever people
want to call me okay
so so no broad is a middle ground broad
broad Dame these are name I don't know I
kind of like broad my mother-in-law my
well my ex mother-in-law used to call me
a tough bird tough old bird yeah that's
a good one
yeah you know broad is kind of
complimentary when you think about it
because it typically means one is bosomy
and that was something that men were
attracted to so okay for people who
aren't familiar with you yet Karen and
they should be girl rights what that's
what you type in yeah tell them how
you're kind of big claim to fame so some
people would say men's rights activists
I just sort of see you as a truth-teller
in the third wave feminist community I
don't want to misrepresent you you
introduce yourself to the world well I
mean like people ask me what I identify
as and I like primarily first and
foremost it's anti-feminist and and
secondary to that is advocacy for the
problems of men and boys and sort of a
more balanced and positive understanding
of masculinity currently and
historically and
some people sort of call me a gender
theorist you know I kind of go into the
evolutionary psychology of men and women
and and how all of that works and so I
you know it's kind of a mixed bag I'm
kind of like a little column a little
column B and yeah we'll just refer to
you as Z you have not yet decided we
call that said here is that that's true
yeah you know what and I got kicked out
of class was raised in Canada if you
don't know in Montreal and the teacher
yeah teacher correct means that Zed I
said no she said yes it's Zed I said
okay holla second let me run this let me
run this through for you mrs. measure
ABCD efg hijk LMNOP QRS TUV wxy and Zed
what's wrong with this picture and I was
kicked out and sent home with a note for
being a smartass you know you strike me
as a person who probably got sent home
yeah I did and you know it's funny that
ties us right but I got sent home you
know for like sending love letters or
getting caught kissing the girl in the
playground right nowadays that's
considered a violent assault sexual
assault for kissing a girl in the
playground which is just crazy I mean
that's how boys and girls kind of figure
it out you say they're gross but you do
it on a dare so for people who don't
necessarily know I mean they call you
men's rights men's rights activists I
guess is a term I think it's kind of a
silly term but you do point out and
people would expect you you know coming
they would expect you to be a feminist
because you show up at a lot of these
panels and you come across very
intellectual and and I'll get into that
but they expected hair shorthair
boycotted yes okay no makeup I'm gonna
say it you know I was gonna say it down
the line but I didn't want to turn you
off just like gay Jarrett people assume
in proposition M yeah even people I work
with marry all day long okay I never got
hit on by women even when I was young
and hot and I don't know why that is I
think maybe I just scare people a little
well no your stay
when you were young and hot you're
pretty you're a pretty not lady woman
broad you're a cute bird see but yeah no
makeup short hair people would assume
that you really do point out some
glaring inconsistencies in modern
feminism and you argue that actually men
right now how that worse off that women
have a leg up as far as sort of the
cultural playing field right now on
people throw a fit and they get furious
at you until they actually listen what
what brought you to that and why do you
think people react in the way that they
do um I think that they react in the way
that they do because they're there's
this or the cultural or the
acculturation the sort of education that
they've got where you know so they
they've been exposed since early
childhood to this narrative that women
were always oppressed and and they
didn't have equal rights and they don't
get equal pay for equal work and there's
all of these memes going around that
most of them are either outright false
or questionable right arguable the
debate is is not done on the on the
entire question of the historical
oppression of women right in you know in
my opinion and so but these have all
been presented to people as fact and and
they've internalized all of those
messages and so they have this belief
system and that belief system is also
reinforced by their innate psychology
right this is why I go into evolutionary
psychology a lot just how we perceive
other individuals how tribalism works
how sexism works how all of those things
work right and so it's very very easy
for you know in for feminists to
convince an entire society a society
side is a society that has seven
different federal departments dedicated
to women's health and well-being
none for men that has affirmative action
for women that has done nothing but
pander to women women's interests
women's needs spends way more money on
women's health despite the fact that men
died earlier than women of 14 of the 15
leading causes of death that
you know more focus on depression and
mental illness and women despite the
fact that men are three to four times
more likely to commit suicide and be
addicted to drugs and all of these
things right right that you can convince
society that this society that focuses
entirely on women's well-being to the
detriment of even children that this
society is actually inherently
misogynistic and always has been right
right and it's it's because there's a
sort of a vulnerability in our
psychology that makes that narrative I
think particularly for men because men
are naturally protective of women and
it's funny you know I've always talked
about this men didn't have a secret
meeting behind women's backs I'm like
we're gonna beat the hell out of them by
the way we're gonna set this unrealistic
standard of beauty I don't even like
boobs and butts it'll mess with their
head like you know there's no secret
society the truth is any guy I get you
know I hang around maybe one is a rapist
but you'd think I'd know one who's like
you know if we're all rapists that it
would come up it never comes up just
kind of like you know you meet a genuine
racist and you're like wow yeah really
caught me off guard you just were and
you weren't quoting Kanye so I think men
are inclined to believe it because men
do see women as more helpless than
themselves as those in need of
protecting and stuff like wow god I
don't want to mistreat them yeah we
should give them that that extra special
precaution is do you think that's the
liberally preyed upon it is it is part
of that one of the problems with with
the feminist narrative over that you
know it's it's misogynistic to consider
women weak and consider them in need of
extra protection and blah blah because
women are just equally as strong and
capable as men but that's not why men
feel that way about women because you
know ask any geeky nerdy guy right what
his experience was and has been you know
being weak being may be unhealthy being
you know vulnerable right a vulnerable
person right say about that he would
almost died yet is uh can we talk about
that yeah that his lower intestine
removed
get back to it but true story he was as
weak as humanly possible and his
colostomy bag blew up on his on a
significant other sorry continued Karen
I don't know if I can follow it's a true
story a story but no essentially you
have an a completely different attitude
toward men who are weak from men yeah
then toward like they're getting their
underpants pulled up over their heads
and getting stuffed into lockers right
whereas the drew fragile weak helpless
women are being protected this is true
by the majority of men right and there's
that impulse there and you find even
like I hear feminists saying all the
time you know like the reason why the
suicide rate for men is so high is
because we teach boys and girls that
they're different and and we teach boys
that their feelings don't matter and
these are things that happen you know
boys are encouraged to play further away
from the parents they're encouraged to
be more independent
they are they're more they tend to fuss
more but they parents wait longer before
picking them up and comfort them for
less time on average and with girls
right but her problem is that she can't
see why we treat boys that way the
reason why we treat boys that way is
because we're preparing them for what's
gonna happen when they sprout a little
shaggy here and get the little bump in
their throat and their voice cracks at
which point even feminists are gonna be
like oh yeah you whiny piss baby I'm
just gonna drink your male tears right
nobody cares how they feel once they
start actually sprouting something
they're so gross there's nothing more
gross than like a 13 year old sticky
teenage boy with a laptop well agree
okay no one likes them you don't get any
free pass and even just grown men right
look at look at even somebody who wants
to draw attention to the suicide rate in
men I can get away with it
but you know when men actually do that
what tends to happen is some
we'll bring up that women attempt
suicide more than men that's another
fact that isn't quite you know in
evidence I have never actually seen a
piece of data well that would be
horrible if that is true because that
would be proof that women are more inept
at suicide yeah they're either
incompetent or they don't really mean it
yeah yeah well we had a guy actually who
jumped in Montreal from the Eaton Center
I knew kids who were friends with him he
jumped from the Eaton Center which is
four storeys in Montreal it's like that
it's like you know we have the second
city in Montreal you go downtown
subterranean and they found him on a
security camera for three days prior on
his lunch break walking back and forth
on that walk before he actually threw
himself over turned out he had some kind
of debts that you know his he wouldn't
have been able to protect his family
from he thought that was a better option
to protect his family and that really
shocked me as a kid going like well I
mean this is not a guy who was trying to
this was a guy who absolutely wanted out
and it's very very different and I think
people need to take that into account
when doing with the stats they really do
but you know if you if you if you bring
up male suicide as a man you'll have
people say well women attempt it more
and you're just trying to make men out
to be the real victims of suicide as if
it's almost like they cannot think other
than in zero sum terms right when you
say men are acts also victims of X yes
right they assume that you're saying oh
so you're saying men are the real
victims of X right and nobody else can
be a victim of it that's important
because I also I'm not in the men's
rights camp where you get these people
on you were like actually men I don't I
don't want any special concessions made
for men I think I'm totally fine with
acknowledging that we're different some
advantages women will have some
advantages men will have and we're fine
with it and they've been largely
unwritten but agreed upon since the
beginning of time and I'm ok with that
ya know the issue for me is that what
feminism has seemed to want to do is
give women all of the advantages that
men have historically enjoyed but none
of the disadvantages and to maintain all
of the historic privileges
of women so if you look if you go back
in you know all to the 1700s and
Blackstone's commentaries on the laws of
England and Wales you'll find that there
there is a provision in the criminal law
at that time for domestic violence to
protect women from domestic violence one
second because I know the point you're
going and I dig it but we have to keep
the lights on from these evil capitalist
sponsors oh so girl rights what Karen
strong we will be back after this break
if you leave you're a patriarchal
we're back with Karen sorry I cut you
off but I've heard you made this point
because I've watched your long talks on
YouTube pillar to post and you were
talking about the critical criminal
justice provisions for domestic abuse
the floor is yours
so essentially you know as far back is
Blackstone probably earlier you
essentially had Blackstone not only did
he did he include these provisions that
protect women that women have the
security of the piece against their
husbands but he he also went and dissed
the men of previous generations at the
same time and this is sort of what I
call one good man syndrome right so
Blackstone is like this revolutionary
man right modern times you know the in
the more enlightened era of charles ii
he's saying those men back then were
really horrible and violent with their
wives but we men now we're better than
that right and so then you go
fast-forward to Theodore Roosevelt in
1906 in his State of the Union address
and he was proposing bringing back the
corporal punishment the whipping post
whipping post specifically for men who
beat their wives and doesn't sound like
that secret patriarchy meeting we've
been hearing oh no it really doesn't but
at the same time the response to women
who beat their husbands that was all
dealt with by the community it was an
informal thing and it was dealt with by
the community and the men were shamed
they were people would the neighbors
would gather around the house and bang
pots and pans and call him like a [ __ ]
or whatever I just can I say that you
can call somebody a [ __ ] you can't
actually refer to the anatomy because
I've heard someone call Barack Obama a
[ __ ] actually on this home station here
in Detroit but you can't say she had a
glorious mmm so continued
these are the rules when we go to the
web extended version afterward you can
say whatever you want yeah that'll make
me happy because I have I get stressed
out when I can't f-bomb all over the
place my opponent but but essentially so
you had that or you had the riding the
donkey backwards where they or they'd
strap him to a cart and they parade him
around town and people would throw stuff
at him and jeer and and call him all
sorts of names the kind of stuff that
went happened to a gay guy I think Texas
A&M was a national outrage this is
another Tuesday night for the pans in
the block who got swatted by Lucy yeah
in the 16 and 17 and you know but one of
the interesting things about it is like
some feminists came along with their
revolutionary idea that domestic hitting
your wife is wrong nobody actually knew
it society supported it and all of this
stuff that we all bought it because you
know because it actually some men hit
their wives and because of that you know
it's like it's easy for us we get so
outraged by it when you see that
happening and you can see it in these
and that's why it's the measurements on
the street where you know you have a man
who's being rough with a woman and it's
all staged and and there was one where
he had three guys rush him and they
shoved him down and he got all scabby on
his arm and he had to yell we're filming
were filming this in Central Park and
the black guys grabbed him it's not the
one yeah yeah because he was being rough
with his girlfriend right and and at the
same time they reversed it and she was
like she almost threw him through a
plate-glass window right and like pushed
him into it and you could see the glass
just like and and guys were laughing and
and they were like walking by and like
smacking him across the head like
joining in helping her out beating the
guy
so we we have this way of like I don't I
don't understand how we can live under
this collective delusion where we
somehow think that there's a war on
women and that gender violence against
women is normalized and supported by
society and and it's like a function of
patriarchal masculinity patriarchal
masculinity we have an entire body of
Western literature
going back hundreds and hundreds of
years that defines the hero of the story
as the guy who is willing to avenge
wrongs done against a woman and the
villain is instantly identified by his
willingness to harm a woman or even be
mean to her right yeah well women or
children generally speaking and that
kind of goes back to the idea that you
know it's it's one of those things and
I've talked about this by the way my
wife has swatted me we've talked about
it here on air and I'm okay with it I've
you know can I say deserve it no and she
didn't beat me but what why are you not
in your no I I think I've witnessed the
99% time okay you know he's like you
know every time I get punched in the
face you know there's some point where
I'm driving home you know and I'm
thinking to myself
you know I was kind of actually being a
dick back there right yeah not every
beating just falls from the sky yeah
it's uh it's uh I'm not trying to be a
dick about it you know but yeah I I had
you know my wife did it and I kind of
and then what's funny is I totally
juiced it for all it was worth
I was thinking I can't believe you if I
did that your father is here the cops
are here
I just and I walk you know I like left
to grab a drink and acted like I was
upset but really I was just thinking
just put that one on the ledger for for
Steven because I'm walking out of this
one a winner
so that's just like I'm okay that's why
I want to make clear I'm not whining and
saying MIT no I'm fine with it I'm fine
that every now and then I get swatted
because my wife thinks it's acceptable
because I cross the line and I don't get
to do it with her on the flip side she
puts up with a lot of stuff that I do
that I would not put up with I would be
like what are you doing these are stupid
decisions I do stupid stuff Karen I do
very stupid thanks agreed but here's the
thing that that drives me crazy because
I think that domestic violence there
there are several different types of
domestic violence right so you got
you've got the mutually combative couple
it's never funny and sometimes it's
funny and and then there's there's
unilateral female violence against a
male partner
and then there's unilateral mail
violence against a female partner and
that is actually the most rare form that
there is female violence sort of known
mutual violence is twice as common where
the woman is extremely sometimes
extremely violent and the man never hits
back she's trying to stab him and he
doesn't even he just grabs her wrists
and and never actually retaliates right
but you have these couples that are well
that's why also real quick domestic
violence is higher and lesbian
households people don't want to
acknowledge that they don't they don't
and but you have you have this sort of
this big huge swath of cases that are
mutually violent and most of those fall
into something called common couple
violence so it's a push or it's a shove
or it's a slap you know and it's it's
generally external triggers you know
there's the mother-in-law's visiting or
you know there's they're going bankrupt
or something like that there's someone
lost a job and they can't pay their
bills there's something there that's
making life really stressful one second
because I want to continue this let's
keep you on air for one more segment and
then we'll go to the web extended
because I want my audience to hear this
gay Jarrod find out the show clock
because I don't know exactly how much
time we have the next segment girl
rights what back after this we are back
in the second hour we don't usually do
this usually we go straight to the web
extended version but I felt like it
required some context because I just
sort of let the bomb drop that my wife
beats me so Karen you were talking about
the domestic abuse statistics and
information which I find incredibly
interesting again the floor is yours
well okay there there is a difference
between I think violence and abuse and a
common couple violence sort of
illustrates this you have you have a
couple that they're having a really hard
time for whatever reason and and they
are arguing they're having conflict and
one of them will push one you know push
the other or slap or whatever right and
it's just out of frustration and stress
and typically those cases they're
they're extremely minor incidents they
don't tend to repeat once the stress is
alleviated you know you you went in you
you did your consumer proposal and now
you have a way out of those bills or
whatever you
your mother-in-law goes away once that
stressor is gone the incidents don't
repeat it's just how humans are when
they get really really stressed out and
they're they have conflict sometimes
they will engage in mild violence those
I think they need to be dealt with from
a public health perspective rather than
from a criminal perspective because if
you have a situation where a a wife
slaps her husband and then he pushes her
back or pushes her out of the way to
leave the house he he's probably going
to be the one arrested and charged right
yeah so even if he's he's just defending
himself if she has any marks on her even
if she doesn't have marks on her and he
does he's probably going to be the one
arrested because of the model of
domestic violence that we use in our
legislation and policy which is written
by feminists and it's all based on
patriarchal norms and the subordination
of women and male dominance and all
kinds of other BS that doesn't actually
make any sense
still on terrestrial knowyou're let me
go through real really quickly because I
want to get to off in the weeds is we go
to the web extended version we can spend
as much time on those individual cases
so let me just kind of go rapid fire
with you real quick for people who don't
really know so like a common myth and I
just want to say true or untrue and then
we'll sort of circle back men make more
for the exact same job as a woman oh
that's total BS okay
men are more likely to perpetuate
perpetrate perpetuate to perpetrate
domestic violence know that men tend to
be the ones to commit sexual assault at
a much higher rate toward women not at a
much higher rate gender symmetry well
that's when I was leading because I know
if you take account actually the prison
rapes men are it's actually more
frequently if you look at those are
those are all perpetrated by men they
are perpetrated by men I against men yes
I don't
don't like to categorize the rape that
happens out in society it's it's a
completely different thing from what
happens in prisons in prisons it's
encouraged by staff either way somebody
needs a self so let's go on to that men
tend to think of women as unintelligent
subservient or second-class citizens to
men well I'm just trying to go through
the things where everyone talks about it
you know right now we have this trend on
Twitter where these are just things that
people believe to be self-evident
I remember watching something with you
and I can never say his name [ __ ] in
court the Young Turks guy younger he
sounds like every single like Lebanese
guy from Montreal who talks like this
what's wrong with you can you know you
want to give you that whether you come
in you talk like that you know I'm
talking about those guys like the Greeks
and the Lebanese in Montreal it's that
sort of mix of the cadence and the
french-canadian and they put the cuss
word at the end of their sentence oh it
makes me feel dirty
he was really mad that you talked about
women having the right to vote so here's
one that's sort of I think is just a
great it's a golden calf that you're not
allowed to attack now you talked about
women who were polled in Europe when
given the right to vote and most of them
didn't want it now
everyone goes are you saying women have
the right to vote no you were making the
point why did they not want the right to
vote
that's important because things came
along with which men were burdened that
women were not burdened and they thought
the vote came with those burdens correct
so I want you to clarify that they did
actually the even in 1917 the Supreme
Court of the u.s. sort of codified it in
legal precedent that the draft was
connected to citizenship rights it was a
a required obligation on the part of
citizens in return for the rights
granted by government which would
include the right to vote but as well as
that there was civil conscription which
included things like posses and Buck
bucket brigades if you were ordered by a
fire marshal a duty to assist the police
if required if if ordered to going
further back there were things called
hue and cry laws which essentially
mailed by Stan
adult male by standards standards could
be held criminally culpable for not
intervening if someone was being
assaulted and was or robbed or whatever
and was raising a hue and cry that was
the series finale of Seinfeld there you
go that used to be law
it used to be law and now they're trying
to bring it back but so these were all
duties of citizenship that men had and
women never I mean women didn't even get
drafted to pick up litter from the sides
of highways for you know during wartime
or or if there was need or whatever they
they didn't have to they didn't have to
do mandatory war work nothing they got
their vote for free right and they
maintained a lot of the female
privileges that they would have that
they were afraid that they would lose
like husbands responsibilities to
financially provide for them and
immunity from repayment of their own
debts and things like that so exactly
well that comes that also is very tough
for leftists to swallow because it it
flies in the face of well voting is just
a birthright what was actually really
considered a privilege especially when
you're considering a representative
Republic and that's because you know you
have the Bernie Sanders syndrome now
we're parasites will eventually devour
their hosts if they can just vote in
their own self-interests and not have
any other responsibilities it's great to
just say yeah I want to vote for that so
you can pass the bill to this guy when
there was a time where both women and
men and I think this is pivotal this is
just me interjecting when both women and
men felt responsible for themselves
women said well that's an additional
responsibility that falls on me not the
taxpayer not the men and I don't know if
I want and what was the number of women
was that 70 percent were opposed to it
um it was a post card poll so I'm sure
that they didn't have 100% you know
response rate only the people who really
cared about the issue would probably
have gone and sent the postcards back
too I was thinking John Stuart Mill who
proposed it but you you had 70 percent
of the women who cared enough one way or
the other saying no we don't want this
and 30 percent saying yes we want the
vote and so you know and part of me is
like what were these women stupid didn't
they realize that they would get
the vote for free like without any
publication like what have they been
smoking that they don't realize that
they're gonna just get it handed to them
yeah so well pod didn't have his high
THC content back then so we can rule
that out I must have been something
maybe that some shrooms going on I don't
know I mean they were teetotalers so
they probably weren't drinking so I
don't know I don't know yeah it's a good
point though on and again to clarify
making sure that people listening aren't
appalled and have their little hate
tweets ready no one here saying women
didn't deserve the right to vote it's an
interesting historical context as to why
the women who were engaged in the
political process did not want the right
to vote yeah they essentially
essentially it was pretty much the same
afternoon that the majority of women
decided that they wanted it that they
were granted the right to vote but you
know what's the government's supposed to
do is seventy percent of women don't
want this yeah we're gonna make them
have it right without drafting them yeah
well I mean but they would never have
drafted women they would never have done
that well we just had we just had
someone calling last week who was a
sergeant in the Marines and I don't know
if he said a study that just came out
all-male squads when compared to gender
integrated squads so not even all-male
vs. all-female outperformed women on
every single task and there's a reason
that actually there's a reason men women
are segregated in prison there's a
reason men and women are segregated with
you know these really Defense Forces the
IDF is in this sergeant in the Marines
who called in was very cute actually
people immediately wanted it for their
like she's a sexy voice right here on
this team on you listeners she's a nice
she's a nice woman
she said the big problem was that the
men felt so responsible for the women it
was distracting this whole myth of never
leave a man behind walls BS sometimes
you have to leave a man behind but none
of the men in a squad would leave a
woman behind no they won't and and it
also it there there's a thing that
happens to men when men can operate very
very well in a group of only men and
they hash out their pecking order and
and they sort of deal with things in
that way that in
in a reasonable fashion and they get
along and they force themselves to get
along and you even if they don't like
each other or they fight it out and then
it's over after the fight ya know and
then everybody's got renewed respect for
even the guy who got pummeled right you
know well you stood up for yourself you
know good on you kid you introduced a
woman into that type of environment
especially especially a high-stress
environment where it's it's absolutely
mandatory that people work together
efficiently and and cohesively and you
get a completely different dynamic
between the men yeah
it changes it entirely and you know
that's one thing too with the whole the
transgender and the Don't Ask Don't Tell
and now we have to all tell the military
was a microcosm that was entirely free
of politics or sort of cultural I guess
movements at one point because you were
supposed to be a number that's why you
shaved your head that's why you came in
you were a number because that was the
job and that's changing now and having
performed for the troops quite a bit
they talk about that we have to go and
then we'll go to the web extended
version allowed or with greater calm
you'll see this on YouTube girl rights
what Karen strong thank you and stay on
ladder with Crowder's video is done but
if you click this box you can actually
go over to Karen's channel girl rights
what where there is an extra hour of
extended uncensored interview where we
talk about all things not just feminism
and she's smarter than me